that's all are you using your night
vision vision
wandavision may have been made for the
little screen but there's nothing
little about the newest addition to the
mcu
in fact we've uncovered some huge facts
about the making of the disney plus
series that will completely alter how
you watch the show
if we know anything it's that the mcu
always
delivers next stop the 50s
hold up yes dear are you using your
powers to turn on the light
yes dude there was one behind the scenes
moment that seriously affected how the
actors brought their characters to life
episode one of wandavision was filmed
entirely with a live studio audience
just like a lot of vintage sitcoms were
while the vibe the live audience created
might be totally nostalgic the actors
were thrown off by the change
especially elizabeth olsen she even said
that being in front of people instead of
just a camera completely confused her
brain
and she was glad when they added the
fourth wall again the whole
thing was just it was so silly and so
much fun
marvel producer kevin feige has hinted
that there may be some
other truths of the show hidden in the
retro commercials
but you'll only understand them if
you've been keeping up to date with the
rest of the mcu
if you've been watching all the movies
you might be able to start connecting
what those things mean to the past
the arby we're gonna use this as an
excuse for yet another marvel marathon
who's joining for those using
wandavision as an intro to the mcu
well you'll eventually understand you
might just have to wait until it all
clicks in the later episodes
wow this is awesome marvel is no
stranger to comedies
just take a look at deadpool but sitcom
style was completely brand new to
everyone
the only logical thing to do was to
organize a sitcom bootcamp
right right director matt shankman
rounded up the entire cast and crew and
had them watch episodes of old comedy
series like i love lucy and the dick van
dyke show
thank you everyone was given the rundown
on what one division's inspiration was
meant to be
we want to be as authentic as possible
that was one of the biggest goals
they even brought comedy legend dick van
dyke in for meetings to learn all his
secret comedic tips
can a movie or tv series without cgi
even be
good in the 2020s well marvel sure hope
so
they were so dedicated to their decades
being accurate and consistent that they
chose to use practical effects instead
of bringing the magic to us in the
editing room
just take a look at wanda's magic in
action in the 50s
they opted for more invisible strings
and less cgi
it's all part of the wanda vision charm
folks although the show might not be as
high action as we're used to
at least in the few episodes elizabeth
said it was hilarious to watch these
practical effects and actions
that's all are you using your night
vision vision
when you hear the name olson it's just a
knee-jerk response to think of the 90s
full house and of course mary kate and
ashley but marvel
has added a new name to that list
elizabeth
with elizabeth olsen being the star and
wandavision being based on popular
sitcoms we can't help but think about
the possibility of a cameo from her twin
sisters
we're not sure if a cameo is in the
books but it's been confirmed there is a
nod
to the series in one division but
elizabeth won't give any more info away
look because the show is constantly
changing
eras not only did the wardrobe have to
adapt but the cast got the ultimate
challenge when it came to their acting
skills
accents they were constantly changing
their speech patterns and dialogue well
then tell me what's so important about
today's date
they'd research and write down a ton of
catchphrases and slang for each era
and worked with a dialect coach to
perfect their pronunciations
we wouldn't be surprised if the cast got
the zoros while thinking about all the
accents they had to perfect
no no they're on the calendar someone's
drawn a little hard
we've never really thought about how
people's mannerisms and how they walk
have completely shifted throughout time
but they have so much so that the cast
also needed to be coached on their
movements for each decade
especially for the women it apparently
all had to do with what the societal
standards were for women at the time it
was so important to the showrunners that
they were given books on manners for
each
decade talk about intense but i am doing
my best to blend in
elizabeth is no samantha we all know her
magic isn't triggered by a subtle nose
twitch
but for this series they had to find a
way to adapt the way she used her powers
to match the era
they decided to have her use magic with
literally the swish of her finger
take a look at her in action after this
what do star wars and marvel studios
have in common
not a whole lot plot wise but as of 2021
they both have series on disney plus
although the two shows are completely
separate kevin feige admits they drew a
lot of inspiration from the mandalorian
the disney plus marketing team is
exceptional
and feige knew he had to create the same
hype around one division that they did
around the mandalorian
we want to make people understand that
these projects on disney plus are as
important as the projects going into
theaters
looks like the world might be trading in
their baby yoda obsession for a new
vision see what we did there very soon
today we are celebrating we've all heard
the horror stories when it comes to how
long marvel's hiring process is
like tom holland he waited so long for a
response from marvel that he just
assumed he didn't get the role of
spider-man however
in one division there was a casting that
completely happened on a whim
and was super strange for the company
catherine hahn had been visiting the
studio around the time they were casting
for the character agnes
someone brought up her name in the
writers room and it was settled
sometimes quick decisions
are the best decisions let's just take
it from the top
you might walk into wandavision thinking
that it's a perfect show to get you
laughing
but you'll realize soon enough that it
isn't exactly like bewitched
we mentioned how the cast and crew were
put through a sitcom boot camp for
inspiration
but the second batch of episodes
actually had an entirely different
inspiration
the twilight zone specifically the fact
that the twilight zone story got
flipped on its head read into that
however you like
we already have a bunch of theories
brewing inside i never imagined people
were like that
one division might not be a musical but
it does contain original songs
songs that happened to be written by the
same songwriters who worked on the
soundtracks of frozen 2
and coco their names are kristin
anderson lopez and robert lopez and they
believe their music set the tone for an
american sitcom
but also for a story with a deep sense
of unease
or a song maison de mapley house of
misery
morbid we know but it's also the name of
the prop wine used in wandivision
in any other show this would probably
mean nothing but come on folks it's
marvel
everything means something but this
could be a big
something fans think the name is oddly
similar to the marvel comic series house
of m that focused on scarlet witch
could one division be following the same
storyline
conflict another theory floating around
has to do with something the costume
department may have slipped in
in one scene vision's tie has a picture
of the two dots inside a box
with two dots on the outside fans think
the design is so odd that it has to mean
something more
like that wanda and vision are trapped
in a box while also
simultaneously being on the outside this
wouldn't be the first time marvel has
used wardrobe to plant some easter eggs
the theory has picked up so much
traction that jimmy kimmel even asked
elizabeth her thoughts during an
interview
she steered away from any spoilers which
is slightly suspicious
the thing is is all of all of these
easter eggs
even if they were real they would go way
above
my head we all know this is marvel
studios first series
it's a big deal so big that it even
affected the behind-the-scenes making of
the show
there are even rumors disney plus could
be releasing a series about how it was
made
the writing room had to rework how they
laid out a marvel story line for the
little screen instead
not to mention this is the first time
marvel will have content literally
focused on domestic life
apart from that it was also a major
transition for the actors and
even scary elizabeth said it's daunting
to take these movie theater characters
and put them on a small screen
there's a lot of firsts that are a
little scary as an actor
we don't have an anniversary living
through half a century of sitcoms has
never sounded more appealing
what do you think about the theories
surrounding the series are they changing
how you watch one division play out on
screen
we want to hear all your thoughts on the
new disney plus series if you're as
excited as we are for more mcu
content make sure to hit that subscribe
button and give this video a thumbs up